helgoland die afg hat heute ergebnisse
wenn die prognosen so stimmen in
brandenburg und in sachsen von weit über
20 prozent
westliche bundesländer da würde die afd
davon träumen
wie weit ist denn die fdp mittlerweile
an aus parteien eine ost partei sind wir
nicht und ich weiß auch dass in den
westlichen bundesländern mehr
menschenleben
insofern wäre das auch ein fehler aber
ja wir haben die probleme und sorgen der
menschen im osten nehmen die ernst und
haben die immer wieder thematisiert und
das ist heute das ergebnis und über das
ergebnis freue ich mich trotzdem die afg
hat gute wahlergebnisse in beiden
bundesländern heute mutmaßlich aber
keine partei will mit ihnen koalieren
der politikwissenschaftler wolfgang
schröder der hat das genannt
erfolgreiches scheitern also was zählt
ein solcher wahlerfolg wenn sie keine
machtoption haben nein das ist völlig
falsch wir haben das land dadurch dass
wir politik betreiben sehr verändert wir
haben vieles was nicht mehr sagt da war
sagt bar gemacht wir haben einfluss aus
der opposition heraus und wir werden
jetzt in brandenburg nachdem die cdu
völlig versagt hat die national
konservative bürgerliche partei werden
und werden die bürgerlichen kräfte
zusammen fassen also von einfluss
losigkeit kann gar nicht die rede sein
und wenn ich meine politischen
konkurrenten anhören die ihnen der
schreck in die glieder gefahren ist sich
auch nicht dass wir einflusslos sind
aber die sie haben gesagt die weko den
diskurs können sie natürlich
beeinflussen und nach rechts verschieben
aber tatsächlich ist es doch so wenn sie
jetzt in brandenburg und in sachsen ein
ziel sie sitzen auf den
oppositionsbänken also was wollen sie
daraus machen wir verschiedenen diskurs
nicht nach rechts sondern so vernünftig
ja wir machen daraus etwas in dem wir
auch die anderen treiben zu einer
anderen politik und ich bin fest davon
überzeugt dass die sächsische cdu und
vor allem die basis der sächsischen cdu
sich keine grün rot schwarze regierung
auf dauer gefallen lässt sondern das ist
veränderungen auch geben wird in der
legislaturperiode
der spitzenkandidat der afg in
brandenburg andreas kalbitz über den ist
in den letzten tagen berichtet worden
dass er mehr rechtsextremistische
verbindung in der vergangenheit gehabt
haben soll
als bislang bekannt andreas kalbitz ist
ihr nachfolger hier in brandenburg
er distanziert sich sagt er vom
rechtsextremismus aber trotzdem wie groß
ist ihr vertrauen in andreas kalbitz und
wie groß ist ihr rückhalt für ihn und
das verlangen sie von ihm mein vertrauen
in andreas kalbitz ist ungebrochen ich
weiß auch gar nicht warum man das zum
thema macht wenn sie in den spiegel
gucken und das ist ja der spiegel
artikel über diese athen reisen
dann sind es nur vermutungen es wird
eine hakenkreuzfahne irgendwo gehisst
kein mensch schreibt nicht mal der
spiegel sie andere skype ist hat gesagt
dass ein athen bei dieser
rechtsextremistischen demo dabei waren
und spiegel hat ja gelernt sein renault
cius und von daher werden nicht direkte
behauptungen aufgestellt und es wird der
versuch gemacht ihn weil er in einer
reisegruppe
da mitgereist ist jetzt sozusagen
anzufreunden
das ist mit uns nicht zu machen die
wähler haben es auch so gesehen und
deswegen hat er meinen verrückt
andreas kalbitz ist vertreter des
rechtsnationalen flügels genauso wie
björn hertl beispielsweise in thüringen
wenn die ost verbände jetzt erfolgreich
sind in diesen landtagswahlen
wie wird dann der einfluss des flügels
sich bemerkbar machen wenn zum beispiel
im november der bundesvorstand der fdp
neu gewählt wird
in jeder partei haben erfolgreiche
landesverbände natürlich das ziel auch
im bundesverband sozusagen stärker zu
werden und ich gehe davon aus dass aus
den ost bundesländern jemand für die
parteispitze kandidieren
das ist aber in allen parteien sohn ist
keine sonderveranstaltung der afd
wer mal erfolge einfährt und das haben
die sachsen gewartet haben die
brandenburger jetzt gemacht die
hat auch einen gewissen anspruch ganz
oben repräsentiert zu sein auch als
parteivorsitzender wir mal sehen wer
kandidiert aber thematisieren sie als
parteivorsitz
das werde ich bestimmt nicht hier am
puls sagen